ecoute-moi mcfly je sais pas vous donner
votre butin mais tu vas me le dire tout
de suite cette très mauvaise imitation
d'inspecteurs me permet de dire bonjour
le peuple d internet
nous sommes le 15e jour de décembre ce
calendrier de l'avent ça avance beaucoup
trop vite
maintenant c'est plutôt cool c'est à
dire qu'il ya noël aussi qui arrive tu
vois et aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'un livre ce genre de livre qui me fait
beaucoup rire parce qu'il contient des
choses vraies à l'intérieur c'est un
livre de perles qui ressentent des
perles du tribunal ou deux postes de
police qui ont été dits site est
entendue et ses deux avocats qui ont
fait la recherche pour faire 10 opus sur
la police et 10 opus sur le tribunal ils
en ont extrait le sucre ce qui a donné
de l'eau les mains ce livre voilà c'est
juste ce livre où on retrouve 400 perles
juste comme ça elles sont pas commentés
c'est pas le but qui a six lits tout
seul ça se sait se picore dans des
endroits improbables comme par exemple
tu vois où dans un fin moi j'aime bien
ça
celui ci on me l'a offert et j'ai bien
aimé ce cadeau par exemple on va
retrouver deux dans la victime et
superficiellement égorgé au bras j'aime
bien ou encore le titre du livre le
pendule est mort noyé
l'homme s'est décidé à dire toute la
vérité qui n'était qu'un tissu de
mensonges
je vous propose donc de vous en lire
quelques uns en vrac je ne commande pas
juste de l'ebit vous les appréciez comme
vous voulez vous me dites ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
et si vous les avez comprise parce que
parfois ce sont des des erreurs des
pléonasmes des lapsus et ils sont
parfois plus facile à comprendre à la
lecture théâtralisée 5 des deux suspects
ont été interpellés
une femme est tombée enceinte après le
passage de l'expert
écoutez monsieur le juge elle tire tout
le temps des plans sur la cour est notre
mariage ne tenait plus il était en
pleine nuque et factions j'avais réussi
à mettre de côté un petit pécule
mais j'ai tout dépensé aujourd'hui je
n'ai plus rien la femme prenait de
l'anorexie à chaque route un jeu vient
le percuter que j'oublie de vous dire à
chaque fois ci ça sort d'un
de bonis ce n'est un tribunal je le
précisais maintenant police il s'avère
que la victime et sa femme étaient
cousins et qu'ils avaient peur d'avoir
des enfants avec des problèmes
consanguins en deux mois tribunal non
monsieur le juge
c'est après le divorce que j'ai appris
que j'étais enceinte et j'ai donc fait
une chorégraphie
pourquoi pas allez vous en fais deux
derniers qui proviennent d'un poste de
police
l'incendié a fait trois morts dont deux
grièvement et jean-paul dernier une
sorte de loft story oui moi aussi je
peux faire des jeux de mots l'auteur et
la victime étaient aussi sur l'un que
l'autre et ne semblait pas bien sans en
2004 sans comme ça et elles sont à peu
près tout du même délire je trouve ça
très drôle
le pendu est mort noyé je crois que
c'est une vieille édition donc je suis
pas sûr vous en trouviez beaucoup en
tout cas je vous mets un lien dans la
description
je vous mets également de l'amour en ces
fêtes de noël parce que parce que
j'espère vraiment que cette petite idée
de calendrier de l'avent vous plaît moi
ça me plaît beaucoup de versailles pour
présenter plein de choses différentes
qui me plaît que ce soit des jeux des
livres un peu complexes et des choses
beaucoup plus légère on peut sans parler
dans les commentaires on peut sans
parler le 22 septembre 2018 à l'olympia
c'est vous qui voyez mettez un pou si
c'est pas encore fait abonnez-vous si
c'est pas encore fait et qui fait parce
que je pense que vous êtes bientôt en
vacances à demain matin 6h
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]